et nous allons donc des bts débat sur la
chasse et je le disais j'ai accueille
donc eddie puyjalon bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nos présidents
fondateurs du mouvement de la ruralité
vous allez plus d'amants participer à ce
débat on parlait pour commencer du poids
de la chasse dans le monde politique
allait-il charles sapin ce poids de la
chasse dans le monde politique les
chasseurs n'est pas sourd électoralement
en tout cas l approche de chaque
élection qu'elle soit nationale ou
locale chaque candidat notamment de la
droite mais mais pas que on regarde avec
les yeux de chimène ce plus deux
millions de licenciés chasseurs ce qui
est vrai c'est que vous avez une
fédération nationale de chasse qui est
très très structuré très politisée qui
sait parfaitement faire entendre ses
intérêts les faire valoir que ce soit au
niveau national on l'a vu pendant tout
ce quinquennat avec le chef de l'état on
va sûrement en parler ou au niveau local
au niveau régional par exemple lors des
dernières régionales les chasseurs en
tout cas par leurs fédérations jeunes
ont pu prendre fait et cause avec
certains présidents sortants je pense à
xavier bertrand dans les hauts de france
alain rousset en nouvelles aquitaine
dans une moindre mesure et avec un
moindre succès en région centre pour le
candidat modem marc fesneau mais c'est
vraiment dans l'écosystème politique
c'est quelque chose qui compte après il
faut juste tempérer évidemment ce n'est
pas parce que vous êtes chasseur qu'on
peut savoir pour qui vous votez chaque
chemin on l'a vu d'ailleurs lors des
dernières présidentielles les chasseurs
se sont un peu éparpillé il y en avait
un peu chez fillon un peu chez marine le
pen un peu chez emmanuel macron donc
donc voilà et puis il existe différentes
formes de chasse des chasses plus
populaires donc à votent plus à gauche
ou des votes plus aristocratique on va
dire sont la chasse aux gros la chasse à
courre ouh là ça sera des votent plus à
droite
je crois que la tension qui aujourd'hui
après le shass bashing les bâches ont
fait qu'aujourd'hui on bouleverse un peu
les les cartels et ceux qui voter marine
le pen après sa sortie de route contre
la chasse à courre comme doigt certaines
formes de chasse fait que les chasseurs
aujourd'hui compris que marine le pen
était plutôt animalistes que pro chasse
derrière macro on n'a pas réussi tout il
revient en arrière sur les chasses
traditionnelles
en même temps quant à la droite raison
il ya certains candidats comme xavier
bertrand qui a tout fait pour la chasse
et qui a tenu ses engagements en mettant
des chasseurs responsabilité des
suggestions de l'environnement des parcs
marins etc c'est le seul en france qu'il
a fait laurent guyot qui a fait un peu
de un peu de chasse aussi avec des
financements mais les chasseurs
aujourd'hui on voit les derniers
manifestation du 18 septembre -
cinquante-trois mille chasseurs que
manifester on est soit ce dieu une
mobilisation deux mois à peine dans
région de 23000 personnes à
mont-de-marsan ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce sujet très sensible et
que pour les élections les gens vont se
déplacer pour voter parce qu'aujourd'hui
il ne supporte plus ce qui est fait
quand j'entends les les propos tenus sur
la chasse des alouettes aujourd'hui
madame la ministre dit l'alouette des
bois enfin je veux dire les gens qui
nous dirigent savent même pas ce que
c'est qu'une alouettes et si jamais un
contrario ce que prélèvent les chasseurs
pour les alouettes est ce que tu les as
well et les les éoliennes en france ou
même en espagne 18 millions d'oiseaux et
l'on parle d'espèces protégées pour ça
fait sourire mais c'est à agacer les
gens et donc je pense qu'il va y avoir
des recommandations de donner les gens
m'auront bien regarder qui sont les
candidats à la présidentielle et ceux
qui seront vraiment en faveur de la
chasse ou pas et choisiront leur vote
par rapport à ça des recommandations ça
veut dire que vous allez vous allez
assurer sa soeur à voter pour tel ou tel
candidat lequel pour le moment pour
l'instant on sait que à droite on sait
que la gauche et est plutôt proche et de
repos que l'univers avec son programme
anti chasse mais à droite il ya
aujourd'hui eric ciotti qu'un permis de
chasser on a
michel barnier qui est chasseur il y en
a xavier bertrand qui a fait beaucoup de
choses pour la chasse donc en ce moment
on verra ce qu'il sortira de la primaire
entre guillemets et puis on verra nous
faire venir tous les candidats quel
qu'il soit avec un programme assez
particulier mais partir de l'eau
bouillante et pas de l'eau tiède et puis
on verra ce qu'ils sont capables de
venir le signer c'est à dire vous allez
les entendre durant un espèce de conte
oral ces symptômes juste je préférais
j'annonce que les
anti chasse
je pense que anti chasse n'est pas le
bon terme simplement le monde rural a
beaucoup évolué depuis un certain un
certain temps la société a évolué dans
son ensemble et il faut en tenir compte
et les chasseurs doivent en tenir compte
aujourd'hui on est dans une société qui
est de plus en plus fracturées on oppose
les urbains aux oraux alors que tout le
monde doit vivre ensemble et donc il
faut faire avec et je pense que le monde
de la chasse doit entendre ça aussi
l'espace rural il est partagé
aujourd'hui les chasseurs sont pour une
grande majorité des zurbains 70% y a que
5 % des chasseurs qui sont des
agriculteurs on referme souvent la
ruralité sur le côté chasse ce n'est pas
une réalité la ruralité aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça donc
il faut prendre en compte tous ces
intérêts qui sont divergents parfois
mais il faut faire du vivre ensemble
donc le terme anti chasse est un terme
qui est pour moi réducteur
votre discours je le prends bien sauf
que les racines de repos que j'ai versé
c'est quand même depuis 2000 la logan et
les gens comme un noël mamère des
propositions qui sont interdire
interdire interdire sanctionné
aujourd'hui moi qui ait plaidé pour
toujours pour le vivre ensemble la chose
que je connais c'est celle qui dit
bonjour au revoir merci bonjour monsieur
on est cher son fusil on discute en un
morceau la sécurité on a tous chemins
c'est une éducation rural monsieur est
donc cette fracturation qui a
aujourd'hui entre le monde de l'écologie
alors que nous sommes des écologistes
enfin il faut se rappeler que la lp o
été créée par des chasseurs mais plein
de choses mais je me veux être un
écologiste l'environnementaliste sauf
que quand on veut interdire des choses
sous l'égide de données tronquées quand
on met en avant des fortes chasse en dix
ans achat sur l'abus c'est une nouvelle
sentence une souffrance coûté un moment
donné on peut en discuter mais moins la
chasse que j'ai pratiqué que j'ai vu
j'ai vu aucune maltraitance aucune
souffrance et j'ai vu des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui tournés vers la gestion
durable des espèces et des espaces donc
tout ce travail que nous faisons un
million de chasseurs dans la nature même
fait quand je reçois des leçons de gens
qui nous expliquer ce qu'est la nature
je gère 21 de terrain rouge et des
libellules des papillons des moustiques
des nacelles et les territoires chasser
qu'on le veuille ou non sont bien
souvent plus riches en biodiversité que
ce qu'ils ne sont pas quand on compare
la réserve de l'espace et une réserve de
chasse avait des chasseurs de suite en
voit de suite qu'il ya plus de
biodiversité lors les chasseurs
pratiquent pourquoi parce qu'il ya un
entretien des espaces parce qu'elle est
3e et espèces la gestion des espèces est
normalement si tout le monde voulait se
donner mais savez il y avait un temps de
ça j'ai fait une réunion mais quand même
bourré d'humour j'ai proposé de
travailler ensemble sur la replantation
des pour développer et maintenir un peu
plus de tourterelles des bois c'est ce
qui m'a répondu mais là on parle de
dialogue je considère qu'on ne peut pas
retirer la vie par plaisir fin du
dialogue fin de discussion important
croyez-bien ya 20 ans j'aurais bien aimé
qu'on travaille ensemble sur la
restauration des espaces et des espèces
on a essayé de discuter sur ce plateau
vous entendez fonte idée mais les
chasseurs aussi en écologiste pouilles
alors les écologistes faut pas les
caricatures et comme étant des habitants
des villes moi je suis un rural aussi
bien luc urbain je connais parfaitement
les alouettes et j'en avais il y en
avait plein quand j'étais petit il lui
faut des alouettes et aux disparus 30 %
de moins en 15 ans les passereaux 30% de
moins en 30 ans donc la biodiversité est
en danger ces espèces non chasse est
d'accord
les alouettes à part les alouettes et
encore écoutez madame voynet en 2007 un
débat et je lui ai présenté le livre de
nicolino sur les insecticides et
pesticides savez ce que m'a répondu elle
me dit - ministre monsieur j'ose même
pas voulu m'écouter je dis madame la
ministre si on n'est pas d'accord en
démissionne mais abandonner quand on
sait qu'il a des conséquences sanitaires
environnementales économiques mais ronan
mais écoutez si à l'époque avait pris
les bonnes décisions on aurait peut-être
eu un peu plus d'espèces aujourd'hui
notamment les assurances dans ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure qui va
falloir vivre ensemble à faire
comprendre qu'il ya un certain nombre de
chasse qui aujourd'hui vu la
connaissance que l'on a du monde animal
ne peuvent plus durer et à les chasser
des alouettes qui font à peu près 30 à
40 g parce qu'on on a complètement
perverti aussi le sens de la chasse
pendant très longtemps la chasse n'était
pas uniquement un plaisir c'était une
nécessité aujourd'hui on est sur une
chasse complètement plaisir je le
conçois du tout une chasse un petit peu
de régulation mais quand on va tuer des
oiseaux qui font 30 à 40 grammes c'est
ne me dites pas c'est vrai question de
regarder les restaurateurs quand il vous
parle vous parlez de l'ortolan mais
aujourd'hui une alouette c'est ce qu'il
ya dans le summum de la du goût
aujourd'hui dans une espèce et les gens
qui les prélève avec parcimonie avec des
quotas pour maintenir l'espèce ils ne
font que perpétuer une tradition mais
surtout parce qu'ils ont une valeur
gustative encore c'est une grande fête
de convivialité avec les enfants c'est
pas un fusil sur les filets sur la
tradition la tradition ça doit être
vivant la tradition il doit s'adapter à
la société dans laquelle elle vit on
peut pas vous voyez bien ce qui se passe
dans certains coins du monde la
tradition la tradition non la tradition
elle est vivante dans la tradition parle
beaucoup des alouettes effectivement
dans beaucoup de chansons par des
alouettes et si on continue comme ça il
y en aura plus de l'ouest je vais pas
focalisé uniquement là dessus mais
pour reprendre les choses dans leur
ensemble et évoluer un jour et vous est
ce qu est ce que vous intéresse ans qui
sait ce que vous évoluerez sur les
éoliennes
en fait qu'est ce qui est assez
exceptionnel c'est que la l'échangé
courtois il est poli il est de bonne
qualité mais si vous voulez ce qu'on
voit sur ce plateau et une petite
illustration ce qui se passe au niveau
national c'est à dire qu'on a deux camps
doc ans qui n'était pas émis un bon où
il ya eu un dialogue depuis des dizaines
d'années mais où on sent les relations
se tendre les arguments un peu voilà
s'aiguiser et ça remet en question
beaucoup de posture politique je
m'explique je vais prendre l'exemple du
rassemblement national puisque vous
l'avez cité c'est assez intéressant il y
à de nombreuses années au temps de jean
marie le pen finalement c'était un parti
un peu prochain enfin ils étaient
identifiés comme tels et il y avait il
ya au fur et à mesure des années il ya
eu une fibre un peu animalistes qui
c'est qui a qui a aussi avec des classes
populaires donc qui s'est installé dans
la partie jusqu'à maintenant jusqu'à on
va dire jusqu'à 2017
marine le pen tenté de faire la synthèse
entre ces deux courants elle elle
s'affiche et très animalistes on la voit
souvent dans des placements pendant les
périodes électorales à l'aller à la spa
mais elle avait quelques-uns de ses
ambassadeurs dans les différentes
fédérations de chasse qui un petit peu
plus discrètement allez faire un travail
de lobbying en disant mais vous savez on
cinéma10 comme ça voilà le problème
c'est que en direction politique et on
l'a vu moi j'ai suivi ça il ya quelques
mois voilà en tant qu'observateur en
interrogeant différents responsables
soient ce n'est plus possible ce n'est
plus possible parce que même au sein
d'une même famille politique chasseur en
tout cas pro cynégétique et animalistes
qui sont des défenseurs de la cause
animale n'arrive plus à s'entendre ce
qui oblige les responsables politiques
jusqu'à maintenant arriver à faire la
synthèse à prendre des décisions et vous
l'avait dit et c'est très juste marine
le pen a finalement ces derniers mois +
pencher vers le côté animalistes ses
ambassadeurs chasseurs ont été un peu
mis sur le côté du parti et elle
travaille actuellement un statut pour le
proposer aux dans le cas de la
présidentielle un statut de l'animal
domestique de l'animal sauvage et de
l'animal delva chômage emmanuel macron
d'une dune d'une certaine façon est un
peu c'est un peu cette en même temps
c'est à dire que il a fait il a donné
beaucoup au chasseur c'est le président
de la république qui a le plus donné on
va peut-être en parler mais le plus
donné
mais mais voilà il essayé de ménager un
en même temps qui est de plus en plus
compliqué qu'on l'a vu sur ce plateau
puisque le débat est de qualité mais il
est allé dire ils ont été en politique
lionel jospin disait à jean saint josse
qui avait fait un million deux cent
quatre-vingt quinze mille voix à la
présidentielle 4,75 c'est pas rien il y
avait dit quand vous passerez plus que
les écologistes je vous écouterai sauf
qu'il n'avait pas prévu que ils
perdaient pour 600 mille voix et que les
600 mille voix il peut les d'abord aux
chasseurs passe car il était la loi
chasse 2000 avait focalisé la colère
générale on se rappelle la grande
manifestation de 98 à paris et 220 mille
chasseurs il a perdu pour six cent mille
voix et les chasseurs ont fait la fête
en dix ans on a eu sa tête aujourd'hui
poids politique coréen de chasse quoi
qu'on en pense est un point
incontournable et il est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron qui a
fait un peu nu en même temps en disant
je reviens pas sur vous vous dites il a
tout fait mais d'abord le permis à 200
euros il est quand même le fait pour les
chasseurs il a perdu il est le premier
au fait perdu certaines chasses
traditionnelles parce que il la nomine
ministre comme d'habitude qui est très
anti chasse
mais malgré tout je sais la complexité
de travailler avec un pompe il ya là des
comptes à rendre et le président de la
fédération nationale des chasseurs et
donc il a fait du en même temps pourquoi
parce qu'il est conseillé par thierry
costes le fameux lobbyistes qui est
quand même très au fait de la chasse et
donc on arrive à avoir on va faire du en
même temps mais je pense que
politiquement aujourd'hui rien n est
acquis et que la présidentielle va
vraiment structuré aujourd'hui les
chasseurs qu'ils vont regarder très près
les palais les propositions des
candidats et des candidates c'est sûr
pro marine maintenant on sait aussi qu'à
gauche et est avec europe ecologie les
verts il y aura il y aura une fracture
avec beaucoup de territoires parce que
quand vous voyez les landais mais les
landais majoritairement de gauche et
terre de gauche qui manifeste qui
aujourd'hui vous l'avez citer alain
rousset mais j'étais candidat à la
régionale la nouvelle aquitaine avec
jean lassalle on nous donnait 2 2 pour
ça on a fini à 7 75 en était à 9,81 à
53% des dépouillements du rhin pour un
parti qui est inconnu qui a justement de
vie ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui même
dans des terres de gauche des bastions
de gauche comme le sud ouest il ya un
ressenti des populations rurales puisque
le score qu'on a fait il a en réalité il
contredit en gros ce que vous disaient
les gens sont attachés alors à leur vie
dans les territoires et on a su
représenter cette espérance de vie parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un envie de liberté
de vivre avec ses traditions pas tout
évidemment mais raisonnablement et
encore je pense que le procès qui est
fait aux gens qu'ils soient éleveurs
pêcheurs chasseurs n'est pas bon
je pense que sur la biodiversité
on n'est pas d'accord et sur plein de
choses on n'est pas d'accord parce qu'il
ya une forme de négationnisme que
j'entends souvent c'est à dire que les
échos les chasseurs serait pour la
biodiversité je ne vois pas tous les
jours je ne vois pas que tous les jours
et surtout il faut prendre en compte ce
qui est aujourd'hui présent le clip a
évolué on est dans la sixième extinction
d animal enfin des malouines animal
mêmes végétales il faut prendre tout ça
en compte donc le montrera évolué moi
j'ai été élu sénateur à la fois sur la
ville aussi sur le monde rural sans
aucun problème et je pense que en
recomposant et c'est le programme des
écologistes en allant vers un autre
modèle agricole en remettant des est
justement on va favoriser la
biodiversité et ça ne va pas à
l'encontre forcément des intérêts des
chasseurs je pense qu'il faut vivre
ensemble et ça ne doit pas être une
minorité qui aujourd'hui décide de ce
qui va se passer dans le monde rural je
pense qu'il faut quand je vous parlais
du vivre ensemble c'est fondamental il
ya plein de neo
de néo ruraux qui sont là et qui ont le
droit de se promener sans se prendre
deux sens alors je vais pas dire prenez
un coup de fusil ça serait un peu
exagéré mais entendre du coup de fusil
ça quand même ça insécurise on n'est pas
à l'aise quand on se promène dans un
bois en entendant ses
inquiétudes
c'est parce qu'il ya eu une
discrimination une focalisation sur dix
accidents en france et parfois un mort
de trop mais on en a fait une
amplificateur une résonance qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui un pétard qui pète tout
le monde a peur mais faut arrêter de
dire tout et n'importe quoi
236 en occident et c'est de la
courtoisie d éducation éducation et une
formation
je crois que c'est l'une est quand même
il ya une inquiétude autour du du carnet
est ce que vous trouvez votre voiture
est ce que vous entendez aujourd'hui
certains français qui disent bay où on a
peur d'aller se promener en forêt on a
créé cette peur on à chrysler répondait
mais au contraire venez discuter avec
les gens ayant une approche courtoise et
je vous garantis que les gens vont
s'arrêter on est pas on n'est pas là
pour pratiquer 8h sur huit heures être
d'un non moi je sais que tous les gens
que le croc le fait vous rendez compte
que vous êtes en train de parler à des
ruraux qui laissent leur territoire ce
sont des propriétés privées que les
jambes ramasser les champignons chez eux
qu'ils peuvent ramasser des fruits et c
est donc un petit chat s'il accueille
les gens avec avec le fair play qui est
le nôtre
john cena du fair play le
cas que les chasseurs et pour sa ville a
dit ben ali sedjari variable aussi la
propriété privée parce que vous voulez
aller ch associé mouvement mois les
chasseurs viennent chez moi ça c'est la
loi verdeille ça dépend
il ya la gestion parce qu'il faut pas le
voir comme ça monsieur il faut le voir
en terme de gestion des espaces et des
espèces à partir du moment où dans la
loi verdeille vous pouvez participer à
une a cessé à venir discuter avec les
chasseurs mettre votre grain de sel
pourquoi pas c'est de la discussion qui
sortira le meilleur moi je revote la
france et
les chasseurs sont sur des propriétés
privées qui pratiquent la les peler les
nous les néo ruraux mais je vais vous
expliquer une fois j'aime patrons
d'entreprises qui est venu là mon
entreprise j'ai eu les larmes et de
paris eh bien monsieur puijalon ce
week-end je suis allé courir dans le
bois il y avait des coups de fusil puis
j'ai dit oui c'est le monsieur il doit
être à sa part lundi en train de chasser
de nos îles midi dans un bois et je dis
oui c'est son bois ah bon mais il se
croyait que c'était le jardin des
tuileries ou autre chose que j'énonce et
sa propriété monsieur nan mais sait
aussi chasser clôture on est ouverts
vers la société il faut juste dialoguer
et se respecter et éviter de créer ces
tensions parce que dès que vous avez un
fusil vous avez entre vous avez vu les
tensions c'est de votre côté je pense
aux gens je pense qu'il faut que le
monde de la chasse est voulue mal à
l'entendre à des pratiques qui ne sont
plus tolérants aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
sont plus perçus savez ce que tu fais en
2000 les députés un peu plus léger les
verts monsieur mamère et mal à monsieur
a secoué madame voynet les premiers mots
qui disait ce sont des alcooliques
assassin à l'assemblée nationale c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je
suis entré en politique et j'étais très
jeune je n'avais pas d'argent ni rien
sauf que quand on a dit que mon grand
père était un as assez un alcoolique
croyez bien que monsieur que je
connaissais et qui était le plus brave
des hommes est la porte ouverte il donné
à tout le monde qui est un social ça
m'avait un peu agacé voilà la caricature
c'est trop pour conclure parce qu'il
nous reste un petit peu plus d'une
minute vous avez employé le mot de vivre
ensemble et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
le thème de ce débat comment on fait
pour améliorer ce vivre ensemble entre
écologistes et chasseurs même si on l'a
vu il faut pas les opposer à pour moi il
ya des préalables je pense que la chasse
que je disais doit évoluer par exemple
depuis le 19e siècle les anglais ont
interdit la chasse le dimanche je pense
que c'est une question centrale
commençons par là essayons d'avancer pas
à pas il ya un certain nombre aussi de
pratiques de chasse j'ai on a déposé une
loi contre les chasse cruelle il ya
certaines choses qui pour moi ne sont
plus tolérables dans le monde où on est
aujourd'hui donc s'il ya des pas de
faits en ce sens là je pense qu'il ya un
moyen de faire un vivre ensemble et de
se comprendre et le monde rural c'est
bien autre chose que seulement la chasse
c'est les services publics c'est tout un
tas de choses qui font que en faisant
évoluer aussi le modèle agricole on peut
faire vivre le monde rural complètement
différemment et là
dans les vieux travers c'est les vieux
travers d'europe écologie les verts
c'est interdit son premier mot c'est
interdire la chasse et dimanche mais
encore une fois de plus ça va à l'opposé
du vivre ensemble on commence à prendre
interdire on commence par pouvoir
travailler sur les mêmes territoires
avec les mêmes personnes c'est pas un
interdisant qu'on arrivera à quelque
chose et donc je suis trop imposant soit
mais encore une fois de plus le dimanche
j'ai encore des gens qui ont ramassé
champignons si les gens sont courtois
tolérant et respectueux la sécurité tout
le monde peut venir sur nos territoires
et avec grand plaisir je travaille les
écologistes quand j'étais aux yeux la
région sur les perturber
une fois de plus c'est un problème et
vous n'avez que les intérieures jai pas
les interdits
ça a été un débat très intéressant et
comme en 2017 vous voulez il ya eu une
vraie bataille politique entre françois
fillon et emmanuel macron pour récupérer
ses voix des chasseurs là et on va en
bas entre le candidat qui va sortir en
effet de la primaire de la droite fin le
congrès et le chef de l'état qui faut
quand même le rappelez vous aviez l'air
de le balayer mai mais c'est depuis
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est le sait
le sait le premier président chasseur
est rarement un président de la
république a fait sarkozy j'ai revu le
jour de noël chose qu'avec la gauche en
place
mais encore une fois pour des raisons
électoralistes parce que c'est vrai que
ça a permis d'équilibrer son parti qui a
acquis un peu drôle et dans ce
qui est en train de faire les yeux doux
à la chasse aux 6,1 et que vous suivez
comment est ce que vous regardez
pas du tout mais je sais qu'il a passé
quelques coups de téléphone vous dit ça
pour le fusil c'est ça non pas du tout
il m'a cédé des contacts mais je sais
qu'ils y regarde de près les conseillers
[Musique]